I'm creating environment where people
will be at their natural best is all
about making people feel psychologically
safe leading with empathy seeing people
as a whole person creating a space where
people can feel seen and heard and
understood and we have to learn skills
to do that we're lacking in human skill
things like better active listening
skills how to have difficult
conversations how to lead with empathy
how to give and receive feedback how to
have an effective confrontation to give
people some harsh feedback sometimes in
ways that they will hear it not in ways
that they will be defensive these are
all very important skills that go
directly towards building a circle of
safety but the biggest one that I think
a lot of leaders screw up is being
vulnerable if we want our people to be
vulnerable around us if we want our
people to admit mistakes and say they
need help well we have to set the
example then we set the tone for others
to be vulnerable around us and at the
end of the day don't we want people to
say they need help don't we want people
to say when they're struggling don't we
want people to say they've made a
mistake so we could be there to help
them that's what leadership is all about